I think the story actually mine sort of
steer I mean my father was a production
designer my brothers have just begun as
a production designer now so I've always
known I used to go around all the sets
with dad he used to work in Los Angeles
quite a lot he's um did you know about
30 40 films so I sort of went in to set
decorate and as opposed to production
design I was more interested in sort of
the fabrics the textiles and that sort
of side of it as opposed the drawer and
aspects of it and I used to go around
with the set decorators and someone
father's jobs and yeah if I sort of
always had a feeling for that really so
yeah I started as a junior and sort of
worked my way up really so don't doing
it for about 20 odd years now so yeah
nepotism at its best idea yeah it is a
sort of family tradition really so yeah
yeah yeah it's been great it's been
great
no I mean for me I yeah it wasn't
something that I knew I was going to do
from a child or anything but I wouldn't
studied architecture after I finished
school after three years of that I
realized that that was during too many
straight lines so I went and studied a
theatre course and in Australia there's
a very famous - a theatre school called
the National Institute of Dramatic Art
and everyone from Baz Luhrmann Catherine
Martin Cate Blanchett all of those
people have gone through there so
there's a great sort of film tradition
even though it's inside this theatre
school and I was lucky enough to go
there and I graduated from there at just
the right time when the film industry in
Australia was really booming and to have
had the experience in architecture that
I had meant that they were looking for
people who could draw and so when the
matrix and this is the first matrix
arrived on Sydney's shores I I joined
the matrix art department and from that
point on I never worked in theatre again
for me the crown is hugely untypical
because normally I do feature films well
until recently I've been doing feature
films when you would come on board sort
of maybe 20 16 weeks before and then
you'd get something like 12 weeks
official prep or something maybe 16 if
you're lucky but with the crown I've
been on it for three and a half years
and that's the only time I've ever
looked back on my location recce
photographs and seeing how much younger
I was when I started it so I'll join
after Martin when he's done the initial
kind of concept work with the director
in the and looks at the script of
locations and then I kind of come in and
then do a second visit and we talked
about palette and colors and yeah how
are you how you want to you know go
ahead with it I'm very often by the time
you join by the time the set decorator
generally joins we have worked out which
bits we're shooting on location which
bits we're building and again that's
usually a simpler thing on a feature
film because the script is is there and
you can you know your knowledge of
locations means that you can work out
which are the obvious wants to go to and
which are the things you might like to
build and which are the things you know
you're gonna have to build whereas on
the crown it's much more of an evolving
thing so we're going back to sets that
we built three years ago that that are
now being turned into other things
20 years further on in their lifetime on
black mirror I think what I've done over
the years is one of the setups for me to
be able to be part of the black mirror
creative process from the title sequence
of the video effects to the design of
the shows was the the acceptance that
directors are going to come and go and
therefore I needed to engage in really
good talented cast brilliant talent to
collaborate with through each film a big
percentage I did without a collaborator
and you know it's kind of a probably a
60/40 split and I saw a cast very
carefully people I liked people who had
brilliant talents in their areas art
directors supervising art directors who
are just unbelievable in specific genre
or just were were clearly talents that
needed to breakout or designers who were
already broken out we're just going to
bring it to fun have fun to play with
black Mara and so in when I've been I've
been kind of teasing with Phil to try
and get him on board for a while and so
yeah this was this was brilliant for us
to collaborate I think there's so many
different routes I meet so many
different designs I mean art directors
who never break out of art directing and
I mean designers who have come from art
and architecture and all different
routes
and then there's that's this there's so
many different ways in and it's so busy
with the kind of contemporary with the
situation we're in now with television
it's so busy and there was a kind of big
wall promotion thing going on and one of
the things with Phil four instances you
know you see people going up the ranks
quickly now and and say with our
relationship it was it wasn't about a
promotion it was actually just he's
brilliant so I wanted mob with me
working on the show but what I would say
to people is for an aspiring designer
the one thing I say is think about the
bigger picture never think about never
never never be a woman or a man who's
trained and ends up putting a chair in
the middle of a studio that's green and
you don't know what the world around
that chair is so number one design
entirely every building from the floor
to the sky never do the first floor and
a VFX company look after the rest of it
always look at it as the big picture
even if you are only doing your small
bit in camera and and never tell a
designer that you're a designer so when
you graduate as a production designer
for instance never put a production
designer on your CV and so the key is
every designer wants a whole team of
designers working with them but they
never want them all to recall designers
and ultimately every film is different
but the sort of common thread I usually
this is my seventh film with Chris
Nolan's we have a established process
that dozen other directors I work with
we don't we don't do the same thing but
with him he's usually in his writing
phase in his house and traditionally
I've always gone in in that phase and we
sort of had his his old double garages
in art
room and so I try and give him visuals
visual ideas or cues for the film yeah
again every films different so I'm
dunkirk it was really going in to sort
of study it because it because it was
such a well-known event we realized
within you know a week of sitting down
at his house that it was he'd already
written the script was the shortest
script he's ever written and so we kind
of sat there we looked around it's like
we got to get on a plane go to Dunkirk
so I actually met him in Dunkirk very
early on and we decided we just walked a
whole Beach so he walked 18 miles
we can't realize we couldn't fake any of
it we had to actually go and shoot in
Dunkirk and we had to do as much of it
practically it was it could even though
Dunkirk so really it's a difficult Beach
to film on because it it's difficult
Beach to get off because it's got a
21-foot tide it's very particular to the
event and so we immediately knew even
though it was gonna be very hard to make
the film there we had to go and make it
there so that's kind of how it started
and we went back to his house and we
spent a couple of months just trying to
figure out how to achieve everything how
to how to do it with as little the
effects as possible you know how do we
do the flying stuff how do we do the
boats and so we sort of came to this is
a further realization we had the
building of Mada of big ships and little
ships so then I actually took off and
went kind of around most of Europe
looking for ships you know looking for
the hospital ship bushes came out of no
I came out of Norway the Rogel and I was
looking for destroyers working
destroyers minesweepers so we had to
build this a modder so we it was a sort
of very it was a very difficult film to
try and make practically so we had to
someone find planes to decide to how we
were going to do all the ships whether
we're going to scale them down we're
gonna use half scale [ __ ] know half
scale destroyer is is you
180 foot long so you could you can use a
boat that's much smaller and then you
have to build the scenery on the decks
and make it seaworthy to make a
full-size destroyer over 150 feet so we
so came up with all these sort of
practical ways of achieving the film I
mean we're not doing anything new I mean
doing a pre visual effects for donkey's
years so we we we you know how do we put
an IMAX camera on a World War 2 plane
and fly it in formation and capture that
on film so we there was a lot of
practicality Norma's amount of
practicalities and that kind of to begin
with over rode the design theme and then
you know as we got further into it and
we looked at other research we realized
that Dunkirk
you know everyone sees it is this sort
of little you know three-story seaside
town but actually was a big industrial
port so we really want to play with the
the the industry and the bleakness of of
the other side of Dunkirk which can't
played into our film this all this
lonely place inescapable place is very
like I said very color centric the first
day we started with Din office I mean I
had to script a whole year prior to that
even though I wasn't working on it it
was percolating in my mind at least a
rough draft the first day we met we we
basically went through the big color
book and we quickly together we we
flipped through it all and associated
certain colors with certain characters
and one of the main characters is Eliza
Sally Hawkins character and her
apartment was basically in the aqua hues
you know she was supposed to be even
when there was no water it was always
meant to feel like she was in this aqua
world the movie opens with a dream sort
of sleeping dream sequence where we go
down the hallway into her apartment and
there's this caustic light flickering
through the you know water those digital
water and done by a dry for wet
technique but after that once once that
she wakes up and settles in for the rest
of the movie we still wanted to keep
that sort of aqua tone and that that
feel of being slightly underwater so you
know in the script Guillermo had written
that light flickered through the
floorboards in the
the apartment from the theater below so
that was that ended up being like the
the flickering light that would come in
the dream sequence came from the above
as if it was the Sun rippling through
the water and then everything else in
there was kind of shaped by water all
the colors were in the aqua aqua blue
colors and it our idea for that
apartment was that it was a Giles
apartment was on one side and Hurst was
in the other but it was split at one
time rudely in the in the 20s so there's
sort of a deco art deco detailed wall
that went between but on her side was
the remnant Victorian wallpaper from the
building history which was 1890s and
then in that wallpaper you know I had
Shane sourced had some beautiful
wallpaper hand printed wallpaper that
were in the shape of woodblock scales
you know seems like fish scales as a
detail that you saw it kind of an eye
level and then everything else was kind
of you know quite brutally aged and worn
down from water leaking in the ceiling
and everything like that and then
opposite and Jazz's apartment which is
very warm colours it was in sort of the
golds and mustards and and it was lit
warmly as well it meant to be a quite
different so you went from her cool blue
aqua tones across the hall into his warm
and his warm lit place to Dan lit his
side with sort of this Golden Hour kind
of lighting and on Eliza's side it was
like always a steel blue kind of color
so it was like a real contrast but the
idea was that you know at some point
there was a grand room that got cut in
half she ended up in this rundown half
and he ended up in the really crowded
half and and he had a lot of he had more
means he had a bigger he must have come
from a house you know that was career as
an illustrator she had very little means
there was no art on the walls nothing
like that and and Gareth said from the
beginning that the walls itself would be
like a piece of art so this is where the
heavy heavy aged patinated walls that's
where that derived from he'd given me a
photograph that he had found online from
a Indian photography exhibit it was a
real indigo blue wall with heavy aging
with distress on the walls from humidity
and he said I want one of the walls to
be like that and I thought about it for
a long time and eventually I realized
you know I can use inspiration for
anything to make that whatever the
texture and pattern on the wall was and
I chose I thought of shapes of water
literally shapes of water and I in art
and I chose Hakka size famous woodblock
printing over the great waves of Kenalog
oh so we superimpose that in a drawing
on one of the main walls that we picked
as our art wall and then our scenic
artist Matthew Lamech painted it all in
in plaster very very obvious like gimr
walked in it goes oh my god Paul it's
like so literal I said don't don't worry
we're gonna knock it way back and when
we knocked it way back essentially the
mood was you know there was this
crashing wave that went over top the
entry door so anyone coming into her
world was just about to be engulfed by
water you know so that was just these
little subtle details in that apartment
that no one's ever gonna know it without
you listening in my story but it's just
we had to create a little history for
ourselves and it's just some subliminal
it's a point in the process Charlie
wanted to soar to have a nostalgic feel
to it he came though the great idea
Denis and Phil annoy and that great idea
suddenly were like hey guys we'd already
started making the set I think yeah
we're just kicking in and I've got an
idea we can make it cheaper and we're
like we're going to go to the 70s tone
or the 60s tone and we were like oh my
god it's gonna like we just we can't
design sets and this is gonna look
terrible and and so it kind of swayed
the pendulums what pendulum swayed in
design a little bit and ultimately what
what we finally worked out was it was
gonna go there go here and then end here
and so that set itself was going to have
to transform from a kind of nostalgic
reality of it something you'd have on a
DVD in an old format on television back
in the 60s 70s through to playing out as
a real world environment but still in
that tone of a slightly old-style TV
show moving up to the JJ Abrams TV show
and we had to make a set that
incorporated all of those things luckily
we weren't just scrapping what we were
doing and starting from scratch with a
crap set we were able to make a great
set that we kind of downgraded slightly
and may took into a kind of slightly
nostalgic period feeling in colors and
yeah and then we realized actually it
meant we have to provide two sets and
the final set was the high end hard to
finish difficult sort of look
potentially if we were still trying to
match the the great sort of Star Trek
movies that thing I mean the last couple
of minutes of the movie were the
expensive bit from our point of view but
what we what we couldn't afford to do
was dumb that's actually the movie down
because we wouldn't then validate that
the process had been through for the
last 55 minutes watching this sort of
60s TV show so luckily it stayed on
track so we've got everything we got it
because I think film we discussed it
earlier phil was worried like if
somebody starts watching that black
mirror episode and they don't really
know black mirror and we always have to
take a view that you'd never know where
someone's going to start watching the
show
so any term when you watch black mirrors
someone might just start in a random I
have 19 films I've made I'm pleased I
didn't I didn't make a dud I love them
all but the truth is you never know
where someone's going to start and you
want them to stay on board you know and
I remember what the discussion was like
will they well someone just go and turn
it over but actually no it's balanced it
was balanced perfectly yeah Toby Haynes
did a brilliant job didn't he - yeah
Toby was fantastic and Stef fashioned
the the DP embraced the whole lot you
know we incorporated as much light into
the set as we could partially from just
trying to copy the the sort of look of
the JJ work but also to give us an
opportunity to you know turn lights off
change the look completely wash colors
across the set and Steph embraced that
and brought ideas of his own to enhance
that and push that on because the thing
is is that we shoot all of the episodes
at once as well it's not like we shoot
it by episode and move on and we shoot
it by location so we might be shooting
episode three one day and Episode eight
the next day yeah and we just moved
through so in any of the 600 script
pages that we'll have we could we could
shoot any of those any time you know I
remember some days and particularly when
I first arrived having a lineup of
directors outside my office door and I
don't and I just thought my head was
going to explode because some of the
because of the changeover between
directors and directors photography like
Deb says sometimes if we're on like a
Winterfell set for one day it might be
an episode you know foreseen and then we
have to strike it revamp it for the next
day and then another director comes in
another director of photography comes in
they've got a different needs different
lighting requirements and that happens a
lot where we have one set and set up for
a different team one day and another
team we have to set up and over the next
day so it's constantly shifting and
changing in look II you know you know
just one set isn't it that's quite
challenging sometimes well how do we
work together with actually we are we
have discovered I think that we have
fairly stability but neither of us wants
to kind of show off
you know we very much want these sets to
look like they've been lived in and to
make them appropriate to what's going on
in the narrative because suddenly when
as in Episode four the one we've been
nominated for it's about a princess
deciding she doesn't really want to
wants to break out of the world of being
a princess now we've just had two
seasons of the crown where everything
has been extremely royal so we suddenly
get an opportunity to break out of being
not princesses but breaking out of a
kind of royal RuPt
yes and it's nice to have an opportunity
to to focus on that distinction isn't it
yes and have a kind of layered look like
Tony's studio
yes exactly move into sort of the the
bohemian world of the 50s more than the
royal world of the 50
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]